tell me about your tell me about the
work tell us all about the work you're
doing in London now with your company
well it's very shortly 15 years when
when Peter asked me to come when I met
Peter Frank London back in 1999 think it
was and and the idea of playing this
creature Gollum came up and there wasn't
like an exact method of how it was going
to be done but if you don't want an
actor's come on second be there and play
the character I'm not happy Lightroom
and Sean have to imagine someone it
basically changed the course of my life
to such magnitude find a way of bringing
that characters to screen but also
creating a methodology of work which
again no actually has to say for me
where I'm at today came immediately in
the last week's of doing Return of the
King because my birth is the 20th of
April it was 2003 the last big ups but
forever return their King and it was
monthly was my birthday Peter asked me
on that day was literally right at the
end of the pickup su-22 play King Kong
and I saw them realized I'm just I
thought my life is gonna go back to
normality to play knowing the characters
in normal films normal traditional way
and
biggest free offer dream champion now
this means typecasting is no more
spandex suits and go enjoy yourself on
the carpet and play any any member of
things and that kind of fascination and
enjoyment really is considered over the
years and most of which would be again
more with be tourism and learning with
weights are the most fantastic amazing
bunch of people's work with a skill set
which I which I love and adore and I do
think that as an actor if does break
down so many barriers you can play
anything whatever you are it doesn't
matter if you can play anything and
waiter the incredible and of the work
that they have continued to do in the
facial pipe line on the second time and
seeing how moved on and now that
performance is a really beautifully
rendered now very truthful to what
happens on the set between the direction
scientists it's been fantastic amazing
unbelievable journey of which of course
I never had any before see coming at all
it's enough being a position where very
very luckily now trying to brings
northern hemisphere because I realize
doesn't actually exist in all things
with in its particularly in Europe so we
have a place for the Imaginarium which
is sort of I see is sort of
hemisphere touch Facebook for anyone
who's having to be think I mean he from
New Zealand he wants to go and work
there so it's it's it's a great it's a
great time really enjoying it and you
know it's very much natsu to that Peter
of friends and bring all the incredible
experiences certainly have the first
three films what meant to make a normal
film had changed and the work that you
did actually sort of as the long chain
of the digital world is to change what
could be done on screen and for Peter
and his and his team to change what over
one thing what spectacle means in a
movie certainly after the battle of the
pelennor fields in the third movie I
said media I was over nothing could
never be called spectacle again without
first being compared to this event and
so how do you think do you see the
change this happen and felt like every
battle to appeal to people clashing like
close shots of people clashing in a
battle on screen these days looks
something like it's an echo of that
dagger-like
battle at the beginning of the prologue
for the first fellowship the ring
everything's got that that Russian that
clash feeling that just didn't exist
before do you see your work being echoed
some sort of style and some films that
came in but I mean that's amazing I mean
there's a filmmaker who so better
compliment than to feel that you've you
know you've influenced the way in which
other filmmakers
yeah the tools that they can use in the
way that they might shoot their movies
yeah it's um yeah I'll go I'm in the
middle of doing a battle right now
actually big Battle of five armies
thank you it's alright that was that was
really just just for you Stephen I mean
these other people Hitler here as well
thank you for not giving away the part
where the leader of the spy network
saves the day
Kate clack girls kissing on Gandalf in
there what's going on it's an ancient
story the first time around I was so sad
because I thought you know I adore Ian
as does everyone here I can't do
anything with him
that's all I mean anything in investment
story first time around and so it was so
special and also having worked with you
go so intensely on stage over the last
10 years it's sort of 10 years later to
go back and then all the court stories
and of course Clara sister footnotes in
the inner probably to have such a
beautiful loving relationship of
understanding horrified because they all
the first time around were to see the
the figurines and the elves didn't in
fact wear underwear thank you bury the
lead on that story
from the original statement now so we
kind of don't get sweeten them again
yeah there's a museum one day where we
can have a little stuff on this place so
we you know we didn't really want to
trash the lord of the rings' stuff
genetics and we tuned it to make new
stuff new he was growing to try and get
them to have his beautiful fake 20 years
we have anything sorry I'm going all the
way on this is a big pointy ear can be
um Peter speaking of saving things the
Lord of the Rings one of the things that
you may not know is that you've got
these huge warehouses in Wellington
[Music]
absolutely one of the greatest
experiences of my life was doing to mr.
mountains you know
Gautam in spirit and the stand in front
of tower or ministers here at the
Rivendell or to actually see this quick
look to really take a look at what you
had at the Grey Havens isn't the movie
you don't get seen these are a few
beautiful managers beautiful mansions
you say it was never written sentences
yeah it's incredible but we just you
know I mean we've got a little we kept
it all and so it keeps all for a reason
on a product so if people see it Monday
so more than issue I mean it was nice
having you this it'll be nice Fe there
as well one thing that you don't see in
the movie know whether you took that
digitally but when it wasn't looked at
grande where do you have drama there
like the the it's like the 12 foot long
version of grande there the the
warhammer that knocks down the Casey
miss Tara is that to wolf you know a
ravening wolf of fire commands mouth but
the prop itself has a penis the wolf
that you made as a penis and it's got a
very it's very shot kind of a terrifying
image I dunno the wolf's penis is shown
[Music]
must be there somewhere it's there
Stephen it's because of people like you
running around touching most penises at
comic-con for scary place to be all
right you ready to do some fan questions
everybody microphones in let's see where
are they right over here where the line
is and the young woman wearing the armor
buttons yes this this is the Lord of the
Rings cape and everything on here to be
back here watching
[Applause]
person's first in dragon boys better
could you say button lady
[Applause]
thank you my question is for a couple of
deals we've seen that two-shot of Barden
Legolas
my question is does Legolas teach Bart
about our trainers aren't teaching
Legolas you get to kill the Dragons
sensible answer the city owns everything
I've seen your archery skills the truth
is both of these guys are particularly
good at archery in real life and so
they're both sort of quietly I think
thinking how do I tell this guy's okay
[Music]
he's got longer hours and I think about
but not quite as good a show
so our shop
whoops penis
anyway your questions firstly to mr.
Jackson to everyone involved in these
thank you very much for bringing these
super epic my question like my children
Logan and Olivia wanted me to ask this
to mr. Lee but he's not here but perhaps
the casket answer who do you think is
more evil Solomon or mr. Wonka from the
Willy Wonka movies Wonka is a master mr.
Wonka the gentleman we kept on that
racism the house age the young guns a
huge manner told him in Lord of the
Rings The Hobbit I'm also very
interested in the technical aspects of
acting so I was wondering to all the
actors on the panel if you had any
specific technical techniques that you
use Norton Edna character especially
considering that sometimes you don't
actually have an actor to play off of
you know the matter is that although
this technology evolved it in the way of
grazing characters I can only speak to
my point of view of characters like God
really what it is it's exactly the same
all you need all you need is the eyes of
another actor to look into and that's it
you know people attach this whole kind
of mystery to performance naturally the
magic is having brilliant actors
together in a room on a set or in an
environment and being able to play off
each other and not let the technology
become a part of it that really is the
key so it's about you know owning the
character as you would in a very normal
way despite the fact they're only
wearing spandex suit you know any of
that stuff is just about Mike and losing
the ability to lose yourself in a world
to lose yourself in a character to bury
yourself apart something that you
believe or whatever I mean that the
technical aspects are challenging and in
movies like this is there's no question
but but I think anyone any one of the
anyone anybody on this spectrum would
let that get in the way of what what
it's really about I think that's the key
well it's like layers of imagination
we've got tokens imagination and then
our imagination comes in and the CGI
comes on top of that and it's like all
these kind of beautiful collaborations
you know want to talk to each other but
if everyone's imagination is kind of
alive I think the movie good school so
even to a tennis ball or green screen
and certainly in first
I have no idea play an elf and unlike
any director whoever works with Peter
and and and also Philip Aaron Fran for
every scene absolutely as if this was a
piece of naturalism describe what I'm
having before that show you pictures
drawings things plates they're already
shot of what you were looking at the
atmosphere the urine so even though
there were fans knowing and women lowing
and even covered in dots and we're half
prosthetics you were completely invited
into the given circumstances the world
as if you know you're doing Chekhov kind
of with yes this presence to Lee and
Benedict and maybe the rest of the cast
if you have to take the characters that
you play to attend comic-con where would
you take them and why
holy are they going to fit in anywhere
[Music]
if it the sweet I know I'd write my old
friend of that IO right there well I'd
only probably
[Applause]
[Music]
yes the immense surrendering a baby seal
with over 300 confirmed kills
I've actual question when you guys were
working like on The Hobbit like all
three of them were you I didn't miss
both but were you guys thinking of doing
this more and as a as its own film or as
a prequels lower the brains it's
interesting because we did make the
decision to use the appendices and from
the Lord of the Rings so we knew it was
going to be sit against that backdrop so
it shifted of course from the children's
novel which is which clearly was written
to me but what's cool about that is we
do get to go to places that you know
about in the novel but happened that
happen you know get off leaves the
company we get to follow them we get to
see what happens in Dumbledore and we
get to see the white council so that
kind of stuff makes it really cool yeah
we're talking about The Hobbit of 1937
that was written as his that he wrote in
you know in the excellence of in any
other middle is material that stage but
of course the Hobbit movies different
because that movie is coming out on it
after the rule of the Rings film so we
we come in from a different direction
than talking did he sort of worked his
way up and we're kind of looking down
the other direction ladies are sort of
two one supreme them but some I mean
I've always wanted to just make them
work as a sixth film seat base for like
that I mean with the big goal going in
beginning was to try to get the Hobbit
and to be the tyranny to be going into
fellowship which they are ultimately is
would return the king so I've been
always just thinking of the six film so
yeah DVD sit except by the time it's
finished probably won't be DVD seeing
all that in mind it was a shame but the
sixth film downloads you know some
people are going to watch this from the
beginning that they'll have never seen
it they get to start with will go all
the way through and and you mentioned
collaterals relationship with Gandalf so
when you get to fellowship and legless
is he fell and your reaction to that
it's going to have a whole new meaning I
think now once you see where they go
through yeah there's a I mean this is a
generation week we make a lot of people
young kids so it they take them to the
Hobbit films they've never seen the
rainstorms and they're going to see the
film Hobbit movie and indigo shows in
the Rings movies so there's a generation
now that's gonna that is going to be the
way that they're gonna think of these
these ones I think one more question
[Music]
there's more footage out there we
haven't seen this is gonna be the big
six dis said how are we going to see and
even longer cut of Lord of the Rings
down the road or have we seen the
definitive version of the
well yeah I mean there was a few things
that haven't been seen from the ranks
[Music]
what were those scenes I mean there was
it was it was a young Island and
arrogancy little something they were
younger and when they first met that
Vigo and we go look like it was 12 years
old without the help of computers it was
both amazing but there was a few things
and then but I don't know we might run
thought them bacon I mean it's it's it's
awful balance issues because the Lord of
the Rings from 7 million feet of $35
film which is sitting in a mountain in
Arizona somewhere and I think at the
moment seriously I think next we have a
Warner Brothers some vault somewhere a
new killer a new killer proof vault some
they are will that all the negative else
in the civil money and feel about film
that's sitting at which we'd have to go
and retrieve it so it's a big logistical
thing which I think most about got a
hitch around but if there's enough
interest from fan fellowship contest
you're inviting Alton fans to sign up
for chance to win a trip to New Zealand
experience the cinematic middle-earth so
what sort of things might these people
be doing these fans how many and what
would they be doing and is allowed to
participate
Casta you know don't you try you're
gonna if there's going to be more
information on the internet about how
you you know how you get into the
society is we're going to be choosing
people to come down in early November
and they're going to be the first people
in the world to look at the Battle of
the five armies with me sitting in the
cinema and you see that that may not
even be finished that may not quite be
finished but it'll be close to being
finished / I was supposed to say will be
finished because the studio's finished
very very close to being finished in and
but no one butch Lee how they anyone
ever else outside of the people working
on the most production will ever seen a
single you know a single scene at that
point so you're gonna see it exclusively
first time and I'll be there Chetan we
might even get to show you some of these
secret warehouses and things too there's
also trips to the South Island involved
to is like a little turret New Zealand
to - it's a Hobbiton and and we're going
to we're going to open this up and make
it and we're gonna pick 75 people we
just saw waiting in the style so 75
people plus a partner each of the 75
from being a partner so that's that's
some the more than 75 people look for
details on the Facebook page or at the
Hobbit fan contest calm and we like to
thank Air New Zealand the official
airline of middle-earth
tourism New Zealand for their support to
make this contest happen and Peter do
you want to announce this this right now
right yeah well we've already um
selected our first two people to come
down we've helped the fake town spy
network has gone out and been talking to
fans to find you know fans that we think
would be appreciated for coming down and
if we're fuel and the and so we we were
chosen to we love to choose more than
two but you can all apply even could all
but some of them applying it's like
you've got to do stuff but your wait
wait some but the details come out on
the net but the to Chris make means are
you here needs some Austin Texas Yeltsin
Texas San Diego or you either Morgan if
you are if you are can you can you make
your way to the microphone can you make
you can you make your way to the the
question like medieval of presentation
and a wall is representative will meet
you but seriously that's Sony 275 so
they're still simply three places to go
and we will hopefully see some of you
down newzealand remember for this some
this sequence with
I just like to think thank you sir thank
you very much for um
[Applause]